[موسيقى]
سرقت يداه سوارا من الذهب بعد ما سرقت
قدمه اعين الجماهير
بوبي مور الفتى الذهبي وكابتن منتخب
انجلترا الذي فاز بمونديال عام 66
تحول الى لصين فجاه فما الذي حدث وهل سرق
مور فعلا في عام 1970 استضافت المكسيك
النسخه التاسعه من كاس العالم نسخه شهادات
العديد من الاحداث الغريبه ابرازها كان
اعتقال قائد المنتخب الانجليزي مور كان
فتى ده شعر ذهبي ويلقب بصخره دفاع انجلترا
ومن اذكى المدافعين في تاريخ اللعبه شارك
في بطوله كاس العالم لعام 66 وهو لم يبلغ
الخامسه والعشرين من عمره واحرز اللقب مع
منتخب بلاده الذي عقد نيه على الفوز
بالبطوله التاليه في المكسيك وخلال جوله
تحضيريه في كولومبيا من اجل التكيف مع
اجواء امريكا الجنوبيه بدا اللاعبون
الانجليز بالتج في الاسواق المحليه لشراء
الهدايا لاسررهم لكن وقع ما لم يكن في
الحسبان مور لصون بشهاده الشهود
واصدقائه لمحل مجوهرات نسمه اللهب الاخضر
قبل مباراتهم الوديه امام كولومبيا
اتهمتهم عامله بالمتجر بسرقه سوار ذهبي
قيمته 1300 دولار مؤكده انها رات مور يضعه
في جيبه
الاجواء لقد القت شرطه السياحه الكولومبيا
القبض على قائد منتخب انجلترا بعد ما بلغ
صاحب المحل عن سرقه سوار ثمين وقتها كان
المنتخب الانجليزي قد غادر مدينه
في مدينه اخرى لكن واثناء عودته لمطار
بوغوتا لتوجه الى المكسيك تمكنت الشرطه من
اعتقال الفتى الذهبي الذي ان ترى كل
الاتهامات
نور ذهب في هدوء مع رجال الشرطه دون ان
يعرف احد ذلك عاد رئيس الاتحاد الانجليزي
للكره حتى الصحفيون المرافقون للمنتخب
خانهم حسهم الصحفي ولم يعرف الخبر
وصل الفريق الانجليزي الى المكسيك من دون
قائد دفاعهم الذي ظل حبيسا في قسم الشرطه
طيله اربعه ايام قبل ان يتم الافراج عنه
شريطه ان يقدم نفسه الى سفاره الكولومبيا
عندما يطلب منه ذلك
لكن السؤال هنا القائد المنتخب المتوج
بمونديال عام 66
بحاجه لسرقه سوار ثمنه لا يتعدى 1300
دولار
اللاعبون في المنتخب قالوا وقتها النمور
باستطاعته ان يشتري الفندق ومحل المجوهرات
بما فيه لكنهم ذكروا ان هذه الحادثه قد تم
تدبيرها للتاثير النفسي عليهم
خبراء في كره القدم قالوا انما حدث مع مور
ما هو الا محاولات لهدم معنويات المنتخب
الانجليزيه والغريب في الامر ايضا ان
المحل ذاته كان قد اثار حيره الكثيرين
سابقا عندما وقعت فيه ثلاث حوادث سرقه
احدثت ضجه كبيره ويبقى السؤال هنا هل سرق
الفتى الذهبي الذهب